il est l'heure de devancer squeeze
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans le
fassions ce forêt ses annales father au
point 0 4 qui est donc sorti avec
quelques nouveautés et notamment une
incroyable beauté on peut passer cette
cinématique on a pu en sur espace [ __ ]
mais c'est génial
alors déjà ya plein de lapin donc je
propose qu'on se lance à la chasse je te
vois lapin je te crois [ __ ] mais sont
toujours aussi forts ou comme c'est beau
avec cette mouette qui s'envolent
délicatement à je vais vous montrer les
nouveautés mais avant il va falloir que
je construise quelques trucs un bien
évidemment par exemple un banc voilà
très utile en premier lieu alain lemaire
j'ai fait trop près du bord du coup
quand je m'assois je vais brûler au
[ __ ] on verra y a pas énormément de
nouveautés de cette mise à jour mais y'a
des trucs assez sympa notamment une
nouvelle mutante 1 vous savez qu'elles
sont un peu un peu fourbe un peu
violente années 80 dans ce fort est
aussi la taille de la poitrine et
mutante et générer de manière aléatoire
un sas est très grosse nouveauté c'est
l'importante didon ne fait pas tout les
devants boiteau quand même hein tu
n'oserais pas ça c'est un truc que
j'adore ça c'est un truc que j'adore
quand ils montent à l'arbre est nouveau
voilà un psychopathe [ __ ] lalalalalala
oh là là je veux de l'armée je vais
dormir ne bouge quoi à [ __ ] il a fait
une technique d'invisibilité non mais
c'est parti mais le sur le feu michael
ça s'est construit on va manger
bah il est passé mon [ __ ] de la pop
mais c'est une blague sans déconner je
me suis fait voler un lapin quoi comme
ça t'en mets qui m'a volé mais c'est pas
lui il est mort
wen a fait semblant d'être mort et une
volée ma bouffe plus tard d'un phare et
hop on a notre banc et regarder les
nouveautés incroyable on peut s'asseoir
dessus
voilà être posée comme ça en tout cas ça
me faire gagner notre énergie
donc c'est très bien ne me regarde pas
comme ça à nourrir pas comme ça tu sais
pas qui je suis [ __ ] elle est trop
forte elle se met entre vos jambes web
envole toi à moi je attention saloperies
à temps mais il fallait juste qu'on
meurt mais meurt mais c'est pas vrai
[ __ ] mais il fait parti des indigènes
dessus la chaussure m amène tout en leur
campement
voilà alors jeune valise où la bagarre
c'est pas une fougère ça va pas du tout
pour qui te prends-tu attendez attendez
on n'a rien vu oh ça me fait de la peine
pour lui ok on va sauvegarder ont tué
les arts de manière bien gratuite
et c'est parti
on va être obligé de prendre une petite
lampe torche à on voit carrément mieux
c'est assez lu lapin bah oui alors
indigène monté vous y aurait-il des
pièces s'il vous plaît non pas dans le
but d'acheter des temps pour au
supermarché dans le but de faire une
bombe
et ben voilà parfait on a nos deux
bombes on est bien une petite grotte un
truc en la lame et à plein de bouteilles
si bon j'annonce on n'a jamais été aussi
armé dans ce fort aise voilà on a à peu
près 8 cocktails molotov trois bombes et
ça je sais pas trop à quoi ça sert très
bien là c'est génial bonjour je suis
l'homme lumière il est possible de
fabriquer le bateau maison va le faire
tout de suite ailleurs pas d' indigènes
aujourd'hui c'est dingue il va pas me
rendre visite ils sont pas d'accord ils
ont dit non non non il ya des cocktails
et les bombes à nouveau ses morts mais
venez quand j'étais nu comme un ver vous
m'aviez bien agressé un je m'en souviens
alors vous dit oh mon dieu c'est parti
alors où est donc cette nouvelle
indigènes c'est toi c'est pat non non tu
n'as tu pas sur un autre ton attache et
tué lundi jette pas exprès tu fais quoi
tu fais quoi
on est tous en feu allez mon bon tous
ensemble qui la nouvelle indigènes wet
quel était ce bug c'est toi tu café ça
qui les a paralysées
alors voilà attendait mais quoi voilà la
beauté du paysage et regardez ce pauvre
bateau non mais on va jamais option a
juste à côté pourquoi je me fais chier
adorent ils ont fait un bateau maison
en fait c'est exactement le même truc
mais si je fais une vraie maison c'est
exactement pareil
où est la différence il n'y a absolument
aucune différence
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a cette fois une
cassette cassette player à sa magie de
la musique voilà hockey de bon matin
comme ça a tranquillement en oui oh
c'est beau ça on peut tuer c'est
peut-être qu un boom mais nous sommes
tous à l'eau
on attendait serait si l'entrée d'une
grotte et bien oui c'est incroyable
ah non on est vraiment une grosse pièce
en haut en fait flipper merde
non je refuse mollet brûler tous et on
les a défoncé je crois regardez font
plus rien ils sont comme ci au plafond
maintenance quoi ce bug sérieusement au
il me fait peur lui c'est genre de
personnage un peu un peu mystique tu as
l'impression que certains automobilistes
quand tu t'approches sécheresse quadra
sur trois y sont nombreux ils sont trop
nombreux
qu'est ce qui se passe je fais de tir à
l'arc quand j'étais en recevoir voit
rien on voit rien hop là par des fesses
d'indigènes thierry five hop l'amicale à
ça fait du bien de faire un petit
carnage j'aimerais trop faire le
bateau maison mais ça va être tellement
de temps quoi je vais pour 30 minutes
facile bon alespo mie câline à 13h de
bois c'est parti réserve bien le bois je
fais comment mais quelle arnaque mais on
peut pas 8 sur 48 c'est pas mal c'est
pas mal d une petite avancée à des
indigènes nous rendre visite
c'est quoi voilà tu attendais le par
derrière et ben tu meurs aussi [ __ ] ça
vise bien ce truc hein et en fait j'aime
ce qu'on en a à l'infini il ya un bug
journal infinie je suis d'envoi domicile
mais non mais j'en à l'infini mais c'est
génial
oh non et voilà encore la conscience
d'une mouette sur le dos [ __ ] mais je
veux me barrer avec ma maison bator 10
sur 48 sos d'après mes quelques il faut
que je fasse encore dix huit allers
retours c'est sur 48 on est à un tiers
il est temps d'achever ce pourquoi je
coupe du bois depuis une heure a avoué
de la chance vous n'êtes pas taper tout
le monde en sciant attention ce dernier
bourbon a posé pour avoir le house boat
nombreuses routes non non ne dites pas
qui colle au conte gisci il est dans le
bon sens êtes vous sûr je peux le
pousser mais non mais moyennant vimynois
mais benoît le con mais arrête je
pleurais d'abord je te pleurer
j'ai passé chez pas combien de temps à
faire cette merde et où ils viennent que
maintenant contrôlé j'arrive petit house
boat et ses deux essais de trouver dans
quel sens on se doit être sur l'eau mais
attends mais carlo train de couler quoi
je suis dégoûté up là haut
bah oui c'est du faux qui arrive surtout
à dénoncer ville un haut plateau ici
revenons donc à notre banque
comment je peux le si je suis ta pas si
je pousse comme ça je vais pas refaire
un croyez moi je veux rentrer dedans
même si c'est sous l'eau et que je me
noie voila voila je suis dedans je suis
bien je me plais beaucoup la déco est
sympa en plus beaucoup de bois c'est ça
sent bon c'est très bien comme ça on va
s'appeler beaucoup personnellement
souvent bateau ou dans l'eau je vais
bouffer un coup voilà ça me fait plaisir
à les noms hy m'exclus je suis exclu de
chez moi je suis tellement dégoûté
ce conte de bateaux arrivent presque un
endroit presque à l'endroit oui oui non
il ya des requins si je tombe je meurs
j'ai pas intérêt à tomber je suis pas
sûr que ce soit fait pour l'utiliser
comme ça mais ça plaît beaucoup
foutu requins mouret tout ça bon side du
faux dans l'os fait pas grand chose nous
sommes désormais libre daria de l'aude
en armes il va couler à temps mais là je
peux aller dans je crois non oui oui oui
non non oui
je suis dedans ça y est nous sommes
libres il manque plus qu'une petite
heure déjà pour m'accompagner dans mon
périple et c'est la joie
oui mon allégeance c'est déjà fin de
cette 5e vidéo sur ce forum j'espère que
ça vous aura plu on aura pu construire
la maison bateau le bateau maison
en tout cas on aura vu couler devant nos
yeux et c'est probablement un des
souvenirs les plus douloureux de toute
ma vie
en fait je pompe à l'estec dois avouer
que j'ai bien aimé larmes feu d'artifice
un qui envoyait du feu absolument
partout de manière illimitée c'était
déjà gratuit pour les indigènes mais ça
a bien fait plaisir
j'espère ça vous aura fait plaisir à
vous aussi c'est qu'elle ne s'était pas
aimé la vidéo safar grand plaisir un
fonctionnement très vite une nouvelle
vidéo chat ou le monde
et pis